Lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo,
es simplificar nuevamente 3
por la raíz principal de 500 por "x" cúbica.
Tomando en cuenta algunos de los comentarios
que han dejado en YouTube,
lo cual nos permitirá dar una perspectiva interesante
de cómo simplificar esto
y recordando
lo que hicimos en el vídeo anterior
esto lo simplificamos como 3
por la raíz principal de 500
y en este vídeo pretendo hacerlo de manera distinta
como lo hice en el vídeo anterior.
Para hacerlo más interesante,
esto es 3 por la raíz principal de 500,
por la raíz principal de "x" cúbica,
este 500, dado que no es un cuadrado perfecto,
lo podemos escribir como...
esto lo podemos escribir como 100
por 5
o mejor aún...
lo podemos escribir como,
10 al cuadrado por 5,
así es que nuestra expresión
resulta ahora,
que multiplica
a la raíz principal de 10 al cuadrado por 5,
que multiplica a
la raíz principal
de "x" cuadrada por "x"
que es lo mismo que "x" cúbica.
No voy a hablar aún
de cómo vamos a hacer esto diferente.
Eso lo haré después de que muestre lo que hicimos anteriormente,
así es que esto es 3,
que multiplica a la raíz principal
de 10 al cuadrado
que multiplica a la raíz principal de 5,
aquí estoy separando,
tengo la raíz del producto de dos números,
es lo mismo que el producto
de las raíces de esos números
y esto que multiplica
a la raíz principal de "x" cuadrada,
que multiplica a la raíz principal de "x"
y aquí ¿qué tenemos?
la raíz principal de 10 al cuadrado es 10
y la raíz principal
de "x" cuadrada,
dijimos en aquella ocasión,
que esto es el valor absoluto de "x"
por si acaso...
por si acaso el valor de "x"
era un número negativo,
ahora al simplificar esto obtenemos
3 por 10,
que es 30,
luego voy a intercambiar estos valores,
para poner  el valor absoluto de "x" que multiplica a
la raíz principal de 5
por la raíz principal de "x"...
por la raíz principal de "x",
lo voy a escribir como,
la raíz principal de 5 por "x",
el producto de las raíces de 2 números, es lo mismo que la raíz del producto de los números,
finalmente la expresión que nos queda,
es 30 valor absoluto de "x"
que multiplica a
la raíz principal de "5x".
Esto fue lo que hicimos en el vídeo pasado,
ahora lo interesante es,
estamos tratando con números reales
entonces para que esta expresión sea válida,
el dominio de esta expresión,
son valores de "x" no negativos,
es decir, el dominio,
son los valores de "x" mayores o iguales que 0
deja de ponerlo así mejor,
el dominio...
el dominio es, "x"
cualquier...
cualquier... número real,
que es...
mayor o igual a cero.
La razón de esto es que,
si tú tienes un número negativo aquí y lo elevas al cubo,
vas a obtener otro número negativo
y para los números reales.
no vas a obtener un valor aquí,
para los números reales,
no está definida
la raíz cuadrada de un número negativo,
lo que hemos planteado aquí es,
si estamos tratando con números reales,
si nosotros consideramos
que el dominio son números complejos,
ahí, sí está definida,
la raíz cuadrada de un número negativo,
sin embargo,
para los números reales con los que estamos tratando,
este no es el caso,
así es que el dominio,
es cualquier número real que es mayor o igual a cero.
Y entonces el valor absoluto de "x",
tiene que ser "x"
así es que
suponiendo,
que solo estamos considerando valores de "x"
que son válidos para esta expresión,
el resultado de simplificar esto sería,
30 por "x" por la raíz de "5x".
Si fuera el caso que estamos
considerando números complejos,
ésta entonces sería la solución,
si no sabes lo que son los números complejos
o los números imaginarios,
no te preocupes por eso,
pero si los estuviéramos considerando
tendríamos que mantener el valor absoluto de "x",
porque entonces,
esta expresión si estaría definida...
si estaría definida,
para números que son menores que 0.